je veuille venger la mort de mon père et
ma mère je suis la porte humaine à
traquer capture
tibet seul c'est mon nom je m'appelle si
vs
la chasse est finie grands là faut
survivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'y arriverais plus vite s'ils ont
volé tous les deux espèrent que
j'abandonne pas vrai tellement bon on
détendent remise sel
c'est comment voler oui c'est comme si
rien ne pouvait tenir pense qu'on
pourrait essayer pas porto voyage juste
pour rire pourquoi pas volot sans rire
voilà ce que je vole jusqu'à la ville on
se prend un repas chaud pendant qu'on
s'informe sur ces animaux qu'on est en
train de chasser
d'un autre côté on ne peut pas aller en
ville tout le monde déteste
toi tu mâche pas ses mots pourquoi tu as
abandonné le roi en fait non c'est de
l'histoire ancienne pour ce qui est plus
important c'est que je t'ai entendu
parler de cette eau a n'a au fond lui
donc des fleurs ça fait toujours de
l'effet avec les filles
ah ouais qu'est ce que t'en sais tu es
pas une fille selon ses dires je suis
une femelle et nous sommes très
sensibles à la beauté en général c'était
pas le sujet si tu tiens à éviter le
sujet du roi je comprendrais on a tous
fait des choses qu'on préférerait
oublier
la porte se souvient ce qui est
important c'est ce qu'on fait de notre
vie regarde autour de toi
la vie est faite pour être vécu
il faut poursuivre je crois que je
préférais quand tu étais un cheval et
quitte à voler tout seul regard ce qui
nous attend
de la forêt tueur encore trois lieux au
moins c'est le bon endroit pour trouver
un lot